on the radar Zone my guy Gabe yes uh my
God pleasure to be here man first of all
nice yeah nice to finally get up with
you man uh I was telling you we met real
quick at the BT media house this weekend
um but I'm gonna give you your flowers
because uh the no jumper interview that
you had did with Adam like a long time
ago well not it was like a year ago like
a year and a half like a year and a half
ago I really like watched and dissected
that interview so much because a lot of
the stuff that you were going through
with this podcast is like I felt like I
was also going through at the times with
on the radar you know being affiliated
with a radio station but your podcast
not entirely being affiliated with the
station and you know just having that
like Synergy and and a lot of the things
you said in in that like kind of really
helped me and kind of like my thought
process of like okay this is how I
should move with on the radar going
forward too so I want to thank you for
that all good man so for people who
don't know so your roots are in radio
yes my return radio I started off at uh
St John's in Queens
um with uh along with Nyla who's also on
power
um Angie Martinez came to the radio
station for her book tour me and her
both interviewed her and then the rest
is like pretty much history and you
picked this up like took a liking to you
guys yeah yeah and you took a liking to
us she uh literally just picked us up
out of the radio station and um and then
brought us to power 105. and then I was
an intern at Power 105 for the rest of
my college career until like pretty much
right before I graduated
um and then I I took a full-time
position as like the I ran all their
social media so I took a full-time
position before I graduated to stay in
the building she was a social guy I was
Association officially yeah I was a
social guy at the station before
anything so I ran the social media up
until last August when I when I left
because you know yeah everything was
going was doing and then you were doing
weren't you doing like um something with
Charlemagne Marvel uh yeah yeah podcast
yeah we had um a few episodes you guys
didn't do too many episodes we did like
17. that's a lot yeah we did like 17 it
was called Comic Kings and it was just
good that like had spawned out of um
when I was an intern Charlemagne and I
would just talk about like the different
comic book movies that we were watching
so like I think I remember like one
conversation me and him had it was like
Logan had came out and uh we were just
having a debate about the movie and then
somebody at the stage was like y'all
should do a podcast together so like you
know on my time off and his time off you
know after breakfast club we would just
shoot it and then the pandemic came and
then he got a show and then everything
just kind of got super busy but honestly
like that was such a great opportunity
and and it's when we still see each
other like we talk about like the the
nerd [__] like we love that so for you
like uh
you say how were you with Angie like
every day like Monday through Friday
yeah every day for many years what was
the because Angie's obviously I've met
her a few times and she always is so
[__] like you know I was when I
before I met her I was just assumed she
had this Aura around her but she's so
nice like yeah she's like super super
super super sweetheart what was um for
you being around the voice of New York
what'd you learn man would you take away
the one thing I'm sure you learned a
million things but you know I'm sure uh
is there one or two things that you kind
of apply to what you're doing right now
I feel like the one thing that I always
tell people I took away from being
around Angie was like how important
relationships are in this industry right
and I learned this with Angie when I was
working her digital side like you know
like if I'm trying to think of it like
let's say like I I worked the six nine
interview for an example right like I
would think about like I thought from a
young person's perspective I'm like what
headline can we put this on YouTube that
will get the most clicks and then Angie
would always reiterate to me it's not
about all always what's going to get you
the most clicks but like or like what
can what's going to be messy or what's
this but she's like you got to remember
that like building relationships over
time is important she's like you know
you don't want to just go right for the
click bait stuff and then you br you
burn a bridge with somebody right and
and as I got older I started realizing
how important that is because a lot of
the you know media now oftentimes we you
know people want to go right for
clickbaity headlines for sure that
um but then it does you don't you know
those same you know YouTube Pages or
whatever like they don't think about
like the long term
um implications of that you know you
kind of burn Bridges or you don't you
burn relationships and I just you know I
remember I was at a party I think for it
was like Angie and Angela Yee's like day
off I think that's what they called it
and it was like in the winter time it
was around their birthdays and I
remember just seeing like everybody in
the room with them like I saw like Joe
and a bunch of other like people who've
just been around them for x amount of
years and I'm like you know you think
about the relationships that they built
over these periods of time and how they
wouldn't be around now
if they had you know had like that click
bait mentality like oh I gotta ask them
some crazy [__] just to get you know
100K views because sometimes those 100K
views ain't worth the relationship being
broken you know I'd rather I tell
artists all the time like I'd rather
mess with y'all for like five to ten
years and let's do this a million times
and me just get 100K views off you one
time and then now we beefing we don't
like each other no more
I've had that I just went on back on fig
man and [__] whoever T Rose guy is
[__] mislabeled some clip and I had
to hit him like bro this did this wasn't
said like what is that yeah he's like
bro my bad let me fix it but I I just
yeah I think I think you know there's
definitely for you I feel like
you you don't do messy [__] which is
important you know yeah and we try not
to do messy [__] over here I mean we
just interviewed Christian rock and
blueface or not Christian rock uh
blueface in his uh baby moms yeah Alexis
yeah I was watching that before I came
here that was messy for sure that was
definitely but that's not you trying to
be messy like you're just doing the
interview like it's like you're not the
messy one there in this case you're just
asking questions that people want to
know for sure and it's not like it's not
like you're not purposely like I mean at
the end of the day like it's an
interesting conversation like right or
the first interview to do both of them
together and like people are interested
in in them you know no matter how many
times I mute I mute blueface's name from
my timeline oh it's pop Christmas always
pop back up it will always pop up man